what qualifies as a stunning twist in
the beating of a former San Francisco
city official Don Carmen Yani suffered a
fractured skull and jaw when he was hit
with a metal rod this was three weeks
ago the suspect in this case is a
homeless man who Mr carmenyahi says was
doing drugs outside his mother's house
now these charges may be dropped the
man's public defender says there is
video evidence showing that carmignani
provoked the attack how by apparently
using bear spray a warning and I'll tell
you this for the second time today some
of the footage you may see is disturbing
Anna Werner has more
the former fire commissioner Don
carmignani told our San Francisco
station kpix he's still recovering from
the April 5th beating they cracked my
jaw
from here
all the way down the man arrested
Garrett Doty who is homeless faces
multiple charges including assault with
a deadly weapon and aggravated battery
but now Dodie's public defender says
this newly released surveillance video
from that same day shows Carmen Yani as
the aggressor confronting Dodie the
attorney says the video shows carmignani
pulling something out of his pocket that
she alleges was bear spray in addition
to this video she says police turned
over video from an additional eight
separate incidents in which a man
resembling carmignani approached
unhoused people and attacked them with
bear spray on the same street that Mr
carmignani lives he sprays this bear
spray at the homeless not just passing
by but focusing on the victim's face
carmignani's attorney says the man in
those additional eight videos is not
Carmen Yani and regarding the April 5th
video he says in a statement it does not
appear to reflect any sort of air slash
pepper spraying but in the kpix
interview Monday carmignani did admit
using spray the day he was beaten if I
used this
way as self the friends the San
Francisco district attorney says more
investigation into the new videos is
needed the public defender has asked for
the charges against Dodie to be
dismissed which could happen today if
carmignani fails to appear for a
scheduled preliminary hearing for CBS
morning's Anna Werner San Francisco